earlier I spoke with the man leading
White House Task Force vice president
Mike Pence I want to talk to you about
the strategy being deployed here and
I've been watching these briefings so
tell me if I have this right you have
this 15 day pause period where are you
trying to slow down the virus and it
also gives us a window to surge these
supplies to the hot zones to the
hospital get the money out to the
American people so when the economy
eventually does open up you can go on
offense with this thing get these drugs
out and get the vaccine out eventually
to kill it is that about right Jesse I
think you described it well although
thanks to president Trump's decisive
action going all the way back to January
we've had the opportunity to stand up a
whole-of-government approach now is
marshaled leadership at the state and
local level and is engaged literally
businesses and in every American in our
15 days to slow the spread but I think
it's important for your viewers to to
know that when the president made the
unprecedented decision to suspend all
travel from China in January and then
suspended travel from Europe the UK and
Ireland and even before that began
screening all passengers from Italy and
South Korea it bought our nation time to
do exactly what you said and that was
stand up a national response the
President signed a declaration of
emergency around the country we put FEMA
in the lead and and literally over the
course of this week we've been we've
seen testing dramatically expanding now
more than a half a million tests
performed around the country were
surging supplies especially to those
areas of New York New Jersey California
Washington State and parts of Louisiana
where the corona virus has spread the
most but the fact that the president
acted early and the fact that tens of
millions of Americans have been putting
the president's coronavirus guidelines
for America
into effect we truly believe that we
have significantly reduced the spread of
the corona virus and and will continue
to make the recommendations in surge the
resources to bring a full American
response when the President did make the
bold decision to slap the travel bans on
where there are people in that orbit
around him that we're saying no no you
don't have to do that now maybe a little
wait for a second
well let me say the president listened
to the health care advisors and I was
literally sitting next to the resolute
desk in the Oval Office when when the
decision about closing all travel from
China was presented and President Trump
made that decision without hesitation
okay and he has every step of the way he
has he has put the health and safety of
America first but the really inspiring
thing is is that with the president's
decisive actions with the extraordinary
efforts across the broad sweep not just
of the federal government but I mean to
say this president has has formed a
partnership with every governor in
America organized our response through
FEMA because you know you know Jesse you
understand that when it comes to health
crises in our country the response are
locally executed those courageous health
care workers and oftentimes law
enforcement supporting them and it is a
state managed federally supported
mission and the president's been driving
that with consistent leadership and the
legislation passed by the Congress this
week the third bill that the president
was able to secure is speeding resources
to American families help for people
employed by and for owned small
businesses it's going to strengthen our
economy across the board support our
state's and our hospitals and our health
care workers but what President Trump
has made clear from early on is he would
not hesitate to take the action
necessary to protect the people of this
country from the spread and the threat
of the corona virus and we put
particular emphasis if I can say Jesse
on the most vulnerable right you know
the truth is most most Americans who
even contract the coronavirus will
actually have mild symptoms or flu-like
symptoms and they'll fully recover but
for a very small portion of Americans
who contract this disease particularly
seniors with serious underlying health
conditions or anyone with an
immunodeficiency that the threat of the
corona virus is very real and it's the
reason why throughout the 15 days from
early on when we raised the guidelines
for every nursing home in America and
and began to do aggressive enforcement
with long-term care facilities we're
going to protect our vulnerable
Americans but in the midst of doing all
of that as the president said his desire
is to is that is to put America back to
work is to open our country up as soon
as we can responsibly do that and the
team this week has been bringing those
recommendations to him so you leading
the task force are looking at this
recommendation that you're going to
deliver to the president within the next
week or so it's a very tough decision
maybe even tougher than slapping the
travel ban on China because there's
risks if he opens the economy up too
soon there's a risk if he doesn't open
it up soon enough there's another risk
what are you specifically looking at and
basing your decision on and then
formulating a recommendation to the
President on well it's the right
question Jesse what I can tell you is
short answer we're following the data I
mean with the with the public-private
partnership that the president secured
with massive commercial labs around the
country we're literally doing tens of
thousands of tests a day and we've
gotten a great deal more understanding
about about where people have contracted
the corona virus who's recovered who's
most at risk and the regions of the
country most impacted and so while the
president has said that that he'd like
to open the country up in weeks not
months
we're gonna we're going to be bringing
that data forward to him the advice of
not that not the best health care
experts in the country the best in the
world
are working on our task force and
ultimately the president will make a
decision that he believes is in the best
interest of all of the American people
there is a lot of data out there and
people get it from the US media is there
specific statistics that you think maybe
people should not be focusing on or
should be focusing on is it the
mortality rate is it the number of
people infected
is it the percentage of people who get
tested that don't have the virus what do
you think people should and shouldn't be
focusing on when they hear numbers well
first and foremost it speaks to the
compassion of the American people that
our hearts go out to any American family
that's lost a loved one from the
coronavirus and and American people are
right to focus there but but to your
point Jesse the number that you don't
see recited on screens on a regular
basis is how many people have been
tested versus how many people have
contracted the disease people people can
go and look for that data on virtually
any any network including this one on a
regular basis but literally because of
the partnership that the president
forged to create an all new system of
testing that that really replaced a
system that was never designed to do the
massive surveillance testing that we're
able to do today we have a much better
understanding and apart from some areas
of the country where we've seen a higher
incidence of the coronavirus areas like
the the New York City metropolitan area
the average is that for every one that
has tested roughly 10% of Americans test
positive for the corona virus and I
believe that that would be an
encouragement to people to understand
that that while they they may have
symptoms and they're certainly more than
entitled to have a coronavirus test that
still the data is showing that whether
it's it's 8 out of 10 or
ten that that number of Americans the
vast majority of Americans even that
have been tested for the coronavirus
have not tested positive and that's a
number that I think should be an
encouragement to people but also also
factored into their understanding about
the scope of the corona virus in in our
country that's a great number in before
I let you go I just have one thing you
might want to address with the task
force if the task force was to tell
every American if you guys could all
stay inside for one week we would save
the twenty twenty football season I'm
telling you the whole South would be
locking up in their own bedrooms
you don't understand they want their
football if you could just tell him to
stay inside the safe football and that
would do a lot of good well Jesse thanks
for the recommendation and I'll tell you
look I think President Trump has made it
clear we we want to open our country up
as soon as we can responsibly do that
but but you know my last word tonight to
your millions of viewers around the
country is we can hasten the day where
we can reopen our country if the
American people will put into practice
the president's 15 days to slow the
spread avoiding groups of more than ten
not eating in restaurants avoiding
unnecessary travel washing your hands
looking after members of your family
staying home if you're sick people have
been doing this all over the country
over the last two weeks and all our
health experts are convinced that it's
had a material effect on impacting in a
positive way the spur out of the
coronavirus we we think we've
significantly reduced the number of
Americans had been exposed but as the
American people put these guidelines
that the President issued now the better
part of two weeks ago into practice we
know that we can slow the spread we can
protect our most vulnerable and we will
heal our land thank you very much mr.
vice president we appreciate it thank
you Jesse